[Music]
look who it is
hello only et was invited inside
southern charm star Patricia all chills
at Charleston South Carolina mansion for
an exclusive tour ahead of the season
four premiere
[Music]
how old is the home it was built in 1853
by a wealthy cotton planter for his
fourth wife so I felt a kinship and easy
Patricia a Manhattan socialite who's had
three husbands of her own purchased the
historic landmark eight years ago for
just under five million dollars and has
since turned it into a party palace this
is one of three bars that I have on this
floor is necessary yes its southern
hospitality the working bar the after
drinks bar and with cigars in the
library and then the morning room a
refresher bar this is the secret
compartment for all the champagne yeah
is filled with tin you can lift it out
and I just fill it with ice and have a
great big champagne bottle and people
just walk by and help themselves it's
kind of cool when you're not partying no
peanuts nobody knows the estate boasts
10 bedrooms across 9,500 square feet and
there are millions of dollars worth of
one-of-a-kind
treasures everywhere I'm a collector
I've studied our history as a professor
of art history the paintings have all
been exhibited in the Louvre and the
Metropolitan Museum Wow in Milan in
Japan so I have paintings that you know
go on exhibit my Silhouette collection
these are rare this is the only
silhouette that George Washington
actually sat for oh wow have you ever
seen a growler no in that great I had to
have it I got this from the Jacqueline
Kennedy sale and this was in the White
House Oh doggy needlepoint there's also
the impressive gardens so this is one of
Charleston's Piazza's this is arguably
the best room in the house
I would say so and it's like being in an
Italian villa this was the the scene of
the infamous flamingo party yes the
Flamingo party was all over this area
yes
Cameron fella in the bushes chef jumped
in the pool yes it was infamous all
right
these are Meyer lemons are just they
were they bloom now they're getting
their blossoms right do you use them in
cocktails well of course what I sell
like that naturally we had to end our
tour with one of Pat's favorites a
martini along with her son and a
southern charm co-star Whitney Sadler
Smith welcome to Charleston thank you
for having me and just southern charm
now that is refreshing
[Music]